Okay,
this is Jocko podcast number one,
a weight with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Good
bye.
You do not get to say goodbye.
Yeah.
That is the way it goes in this line of work,
you do not get to say goodbye.
Okay.
One day your friend is there,
you're a brother,
your shared experiences and shared pain and shared thoughts.
Okay,
one day your friend is there to share those things
and then they're gone.
Yeah,
of course we think we are all going to live
forever
and then
by the bullet or the bomb or the ocean or the sky,
they are gone.
The memories
are there,
but they are not enough.
They are not enough because the story was not complete.
There was more,
there was so much more and now there is not
and there cannot be,
and I did not say goodbye.
Not once.
I did not get to tell you the things I should have told you.
I did not say the words,
not even a thank you,
but you knew okay.
Because as I knew
the you knew
and that is good
and I am thankful,
but we did not finish the story.
The story
was not yet complete.
Yeah.
So now
I finish it alone.
I'll do my best,
but the story will fall short
without you in it.
But I'll do my best.
I will.
One last thing,
thank you
and goodbye.
And I wrote down those words thinking about a question that I got asked.
The question was,
as an operator,
I know you lost many brothers.
I lost my wife to cancer.
My question is,
how do you deal with the inevitable flashbacks and the toughest moments?
For me,
it would be
the hospital visits to emergency ambulance rides or the moment of her passing,
which I was at her side for.
I struggle a bit as those memories continue to rise to the surface.
Thank you for any advice you can offer them.
And my advice was,
yes,
this does happen.
You will have flashbacks of those tough moments
and you will lose control sometimes.
Thank you.
We'll break down and that is the way it is and that is the way it will be.
Yeah.
And as you processed the loss and you adapt to this new reality,
okay,
the breakdowns will become less frequent
and you'll learn some what to control them.
But they won't go away completely
ever.
And that's okay
because they will be a reminder of what you do have
life.
So live it.
And that's one of the hardest things for the losses that are suffered.
In my old profession,
there was never any kind of goodbye,
at least not a spoken one
because even though it wasn't spoken underneath it was there.
We lived at,
we said goodbye every day in how we lived,
in,
how we trusted in how we gave.
That's the Brotherhood.
So to all of you out there that have lost one of your comrades in arms,
okay,
even though you might not have gotten to say good bye,
even though you may not have told them what they meant to you,
don't worry.
They knew,
they knew
when you know
it's going to be okay.
So
like I said,
that was a question I got and just wanting to offer some perspective
that I unfortunately do have.
But the speaking of questions echo,
it's a Q and a day.
And I know we got some,
a few questions,
a few more questions here to go through.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
let's it.
Alright,
we'll do alright.
First question.
I'm a young officer,
platoon commander.
I deployed late by the time everywhere I've done deployment,
there had been some problems at my company.
Commander had been set,
sent back to the states and the company,
first sergeant had been redeployed to another country.
Now there's a new company commander and new first sergeant.
They are treating all the soldiers in my platoon and in,
in the entire company as if we are all messed up.
I don't like their attitude.
And my gut tells me they're out to make themselves look good by crucifying more
people in the platoons.
I wanted to take care of my soldiers.
How do I best stand up to the new leadership?
All right.
So
I would say the best way that you can take care of your soldiers is not to stand
up to the new leadership,
but instead to build a relationship with a new leadership.
Uh,
you know,
if you confront them,
you confront the new leadership that's taken over automatically,
they're going to see you as the enemy,
right?
They're going to see whoever got sent home for whatever reason.
Maybe there was some kind of a problem.
Maybe there was.
Yeah,
there's definitely some kind of a problem.
Someone got in trouble,
something happened bad.
That's why guys are getting sent out of country or back to the states.
If you confront the new leadership,
that means you're on the bad guys' side.
That's not why you want to be,
because if you're on the bad side,
if you're on the bad list,
then they're not going to listen to you.
They're not going to trust you and they're going to be suspect of you and of
your soldiers,
so,
so that is not the confrontation in this is not going to be helpful.
Where you want to do is if you can build a relationship with them,
if you can try and understand their perspective,
which is important because they don't know.
You get,
you get put into a position where you're taking over for a quote unquote bad
boss or a bad platoon or a bad company.
You don't know what the specific problems are.
So you're pretty suspect on everything and you kind of have to be.
So that's their perspective.
Their perspective is like,
yeah,
we don't know what's going on in here.
We're all we know is something bad happened.
They fired the last company commander,
they fired the last company first sergeant,
something bad happened here.
I don't know what it is,
but I'm not going to let it happen to me.
So I'm suspect of everything so,
so,
so understand that perspective and then listen to what they're saying.
Try and give them some kind of support,
right?
Try and gain their trust
so that way they will listen to you and they will start to believe you.
And then you will be in a protector in a position where you can actually protect
the soldiers,
right?
If you get fired,
you're not protecting your soldiers.
If you go,
go on the stand up for you guys.
Don't worry about it.
You go into,
hey you guys,
you're treating my soldiers bad.
Oh,
you're fired now who's taking care of your soldiers?
So be careful of that.
Now you could be also be right and these guys could be really,
really bad.
They could be out for themselves out to make themselves look good.
And if that is the case,
well,
it's still remains that the best possible thing you can do for your soldiers is
to develop a relationship with these guys and make sure that as they're trying
to make themselves look good,
you protect your soldiers as much as you can.
And if they end up being good guys,
right,
that were just,
like I said,
just had a coming into a bad situation,
well then you've got an opportunity,
then you've formed a relationship with them.
And as you get through that,
then you on their good side,
you're,
you're good to go that way as well.
Now this is where people get a little freaked out,
right?
Because,
because I'm sitting here and I'm saying,
you got to play the game,
right?
People think I'm saying,
Hey,
like you need to brown nose be,
hey,
here's the deal.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm not talking about Brown nosing.
I'm talking about being professional.
I'm talking about being respectful up,
talking about being humble.
That's what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about understanding their perspective.
I'm not talking about Brown nosing of those things.
That's not how you build relationships and by the way,
you don't build relationships through Brown nosing either way.
If you just try and brown nose people,
they don't respect you.
That doesn't,
that's not how you build a relationship.
You don't build relationships through Brown nosing.
All you do is submit.
You don't build anything.
You're just,
you're just on the receive side,
but if you're respectful and you're humble and you're professional,
that's how you build relationships and the better relationships you have up the
chain of command at the better you can take care of the people below you in the
chain of command.
That's the way it works.
Of course,
this doesn't mean you're okay if your superiors or doing something that's
illegal,
immoral,
or unethical or,
or if they're putting your troops or the mission in danger,
right?
They were not playing the game.
We're not playing the game.
Now,
you might still even then have to play the game.
If you were my boss,
echo and you were like,
Hey,
I want you to send your guys to attack that bunker on the elevated position,
right?
Their enemy bunker with a,
with a machine,
multiple machine guns in it with interlocking fields of fire
and I'm like,
we're not doing,
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard.
Now if I tell you I will not do it,
and you say,
okay,
fine,
you're fired.
You come here,
you take the platoon and go attack,
and now that guy does and they all get killed.
Maybe what I should have done was like,
hey,
echo,
we shouldn't do.
That's not a good plan,
and you go,
no,
you do it anyways.
I go,
hey,
that's not a good plan.
And you say,
go do it or I'm going to fire you.
Okay,
I'll go.
Do it.
And now when you do it,
you go out and you flank,
you do something different.
You know what I mean?
You make something happen,
you mitigate the damage as
much as possible.
So you,
that's a,
that's a decision you're gonna have to make.
That's why being a leader's hard,
cause that's a really hard decision to make right there.
Um,
yeah,
that's a tough one.
Yeah.
I remember at the muster last semester,
you're talking about like that,
that very thing like you,
you,
you build a relationship with them and you know,
some people every once in awhile,
I'm paraphrasing kind of what you said where some people,
we'll look,
we'll look at it as Brown nosing.
Yeah.
And you're like,
no,
but it's,
you build a relationship with them.
Every once in a while you might brush the words,
you'll brush and brush up against it,
you know,
every once in a while then I'll come back or whatever.
But um,
but the mission is worth that.
If I got a brush up against Brown nosing just for a second to accomplish the
mission and whatever,
then that's what I'm going to do kind of thing.
And that's what a good leader does.
I was like,
yeah man,
that,
that makes,
that makes good sense.
And really,
so when I thought about that,
I was like,
well really what that is is a lack of perspective or if people forgetting about
the big picture,
you know what the big overall thing is?
We're here to win.
We're hitting when yes,
if I got to tell this guy he's got an,
you know,
that's a great plan sir.
Yeah.
That you've come up with some brilliant plans,
sir.
I'm going to go and execute that thing.
So then he says,
oh she Jocko gets it and I'm going to go let them execute on his own.
I'm not going to bother him cause he,
cause he understands my planning.
And then I go back to my guys and I go,
Hey,
here's what we're doing.
It's a little different from what the boss said,
but don't worry,
his intention was there.
I'm not talking bad about the boss way,
like,
Hey,
this is what the boss wanted to do.
I think this is how we're going to get,
get it done.
Yeah Dude,
don't talk about about your boss.
You just say we're making some adjustments based on his guidance.
You actually give him credit.
That's how you get it done.
You brushing up against Brown nosing a little bit.
But again,
if you're just a full on Brown noser,
you're not developing relationships.
You're just,
you're just an ass kisser and it's not going to go good for you.
Yeah.
Cause cause think about this,
think about this.
Here's why.
And I just thought of this myself.
Here's why a brown noser isn't developed.
Probation.
You've been here.
Here's how it's not good to just be a brown noser does this superior listen to
the Brown noser does he respect their opinion?
No,
not really.
Yeah,
he's just looking at him like,
oh yeah,
he's just,
Oh yeah,
that's old,
old Beko.
Yup.
Yeah.
Hey Buddy.
Yup.
Yeah,
You can do whatever.
So your nice little,
yes ma'am.
Cool.
Yeah,
you gave me input.
I'm like,
oh thanks.
Echo fats now.
Hey,
the big boys,
we're over here trying to talk.
Can you,
can you just excuse yourself?
You know,
you don't want to end up like that.
You're kind of the guy who like,
you know,
like the iconic picture of the guy fanning the other guy.
That guy.
Cool to have around.
But yeah,
man,
but he's not giving any strategic input on the operations and not building the
relationship.
So yeah,
build a relationship,
man.
Don't confront.
Build.
Yeah.
I think we're distracted by that.
Right?
The,
the,
the feeling you get when the new guy comes.
He did.
I don't like the way he said that to me,
even though what he said was really important.
I don't like the way you said it.
You know what's interesting is when a lot of leadership books that we've
discussed in a lot of leadership guidance will say,
if you're a new leader coming in,
you just don't start barking orders.
Right?
You just don't start saying,
Hey,
do this.
We're changing that.
And you assess and you look around and you make sure.
Now,
occasionally this doesn't have this.
There's things that happen.
If you're taking over a totally messed up unit or team,
then you might have to go in there and lay down some law.
But generally you come in and you assess and you make you,
then you see what's wrong and you see where some adjustments can be made.
Now think about that from the other side,
from down the chain of command.
You also shouldn't jump to conclusions and be like,
oh,
the new boss is an idiot or new boss has this plan.
You know,
you should be like,
okay,
let's see what his plan is.
Yeah,
you should both have a little period of like a,
like a,
like a cooling down period,
but a warming up period.
Sure.
The opposite of cooling down.
So warming up,
it's getting to know each other.
Yeah.
This is way out in left field,
but it's a big shocker.
Greg Mcintyre,
he'd,
he,
he did,
he made this one comment where he was explaining how he rolled with like some
like some payments in person and um,
like he rolled and I was like,
oh yeah,
like how was that?
You know,
you know how you want the full report and like how has it really,
I forget who it was,
but he was like,
he was like,
Nah,
it was a full on,
you know,
first date role.
Oh eight.
And I didn't never heard that before,
but I didn't know exactly what that means.
It was like,
I'm not going to go hard in the paint right off the bat.
He,
I can feel he's not going hard and it's just kind of feeling out,
you know,
and a lot of respect throughout the whole way level.
Does that start at in Jujitsu?
What do you mean?
Like what,
what,
how good do you have to be in Jujitsu before you start?
Like having a little nice gentle for I,
you know what I call it was just respectful.
Yeah.
Like,
like here's an example,
just don't dive on the ankle lock.
Yeah.
You know,
two seconds into rolling.
Oh really?
I mean,
I've had that happen and then,
and then I've had to,
you know,
take appropriate call measures.
Right.
And you see and you know that fee and that's the whole reason for the first date
role really well it because it's like,
you know,
you start to really [inaudible] you've heard of him and he's heard of you and or
whatever,
whatever the situation is.
And you guys role and in your mind you're kind of like,
wait,
I'm going to give this guy some respect.
And he doesn't,
he goes all out.
First thing it's Kinda like you kinda got,
you got offended a little bit.
Not majorly,
but there's that little inkling of,
Oh,
all right,
it's something,
it's not nothing,
it's something.
But compared to just some dude,
you know,
let's say we're all training,
some do some new person,
whatever in the gym and you guys are all good and hard.
It's all good.
You're going hard.
Like basically purple belts.
They're coming at me,
brown belts and black belts,
stuff that,
you know,
it's all cool.
You know,
it's like mutual respect and we'll roll and not saying,
how am I saying don't real hard.
And I'm not saying you don't escalate because as you get to going,
you know like things escalate and you know that's,
you know,
he gets to know each other now.
It's okay to,
to get after it a little bit.
That's weird.
That's a weird little unwritten thing in Jujitsu,
isn't it?
I'm like,
well,
I don't really,
I guess it's just respect.
Yeah.
I think it's respect,
so yeah,
if you do that up and down the chain of command to,
yeah.
It's that ferment like period,
like how you said that period.
Get to know a little warming up period.
Warming up period.
Yeah,
exactly.
Interest.
Give your bosses that slack.
I'll respect all.
Nice.
You know,
next question [inaudible] I've got a question regarding the quote.
If there is a doubt,
there's no doubt.
Oh,
right.
I remember that from the last time.
Okay.
This would seem to indicate avoiding taking risks.
Many,
many businesses or many business decisions involve risk.
Often there can be a doubt about either of two options.
Doubt that you should maintain the status quo and doubt about pursuing a new
opportunity to frequent or you frequently talk about dichotomies.
Would you mind sharing your thoughts on this principle?
Yeah,
this is,
this is a classic thing in and it's a great point and that's why these little
sound bites can be a little bit dangerous.
Sometime we could use a little little power soundbites because they are that
simple.
Of course I've lo,
I like things to be simple,
right?
That's the number two law of combat is to keep things simple.
But sometimes things like this need a little bit of amplifying information and
yes,
this could be construed as being extremely risk averse and like,
hey,
if I have any doubt about the safety of success of this mission,
did we're not going to do it.
Which if that was the case,
then I would have done a zero missions during my deployments to Iraq.
Uh,
same with business.
Never would have started victory.
Emma May never would've started echelon front because there was risk involved in
starting those things.
Never would have done anything really because there's always going to be down.
So this is a accurate statement and of course every business has risk.
And so,
so I guess that idea that if there is a doubt,
there is no doubt is not to be taken literally when it comes to risk,
when it comes to risk,
don't take it literally.
But at what it should be I think is like a a warning,
right?
Like a little warning that's in your head.
If there's a doubt like okay,
we need to think about what's going on here.
We need to understand what,
what is at risk here.
Because,
and I just had this conversation with a CEO of a company.
As a matter of fact,
I was talking about the dichotomy of leadership and I was talking about how,
you know,
giving him examples.
I was like a,
for instance,
in,
and he was in a technology company and I said,
you know,
if you didn't take risk,
you wouldn't,
you wouldn't make any progress.
But if you took too much risk,
you wouldn't be where you are right now.
Cause they're dominating.
So it's like,
oh beer.
You're balancing that dichotomy all the time.
So if he would've said,
hey,
if there's a doubt,
there is no doubt he would never would've gotten off the ground.
Now where I think it becomes a more solid statement is from like a moral or an
ethical standpoint and that is if you think that something is wrong or that it
probably is,
if you think you're doing something that you probably shouldn't be doing,
then there's doubt and you probably shouldn't be doing it.
I think uneasy way to keep yourself in check and these days it's a very real
possibility is just if you think that you're being recorded at all times.
Like if you just think,
oh,
I'm being recorded,
which probably somebody is recording you.
Yeah.
Like if you decided you think you can get away with something,
you're probably not going to get away with it.
Look at all the,
just go watch you two don't caught in the act or whatever.
People get caught all the time.
So whenever you're doing,
I think that there could be somebody there with a phone recording you and I
think that's keeps you a morally and ethically in check.
You know,
I used to tell my guys that you could be getting watched by CNN or Al Jazeera or
some report,
you know,
whoever,
you could be getting watched and if you're doing something that you shouldn't be
doing,
your,
you're going to get caught.
So don't do it.
Not to mention these days we got the aircraft overhead,
they can see everything.
So do the right thing.
That's what you do.
You do the right thing.
Yeah.
If you have any doubt that what you're doing is the right thing,
then you should probably shouldn't do it.
A lot of those,
a lot of the horrible police actions,
yeah.
Are,
you know,
recorded by some random person with a phone.
Now,
of course I always need to point out,
but there's all these good actions that take place every single day.
Millions and millions of police doing the right thing.
No one publishes those.
No one uploads those on to youtube or Facebook.
But the bad acts that are caught,
they're caught because someone has a camera.
And so like that's great advice for our cop.
Hey,
act like you're being recorded all the time.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Well,
I make it because you very well might be.
Yeah.
So do the right thing.
Next question.
Thank God I didn't have cameras when I was a kid for all the dumb stuff I did.
Yeah.
I always want to make sure that I'm not sitting here saying like,
everyone out there should do the right thing.
We like me.
I'm not saying that if he thought I was saying that,
I'm not saying that and I apologize for even sounding that way.
Like I was as dumb and stupid as the next person and still do dumb stuff.
Try not to you the man.
You don't do dumb stuff.
Right.
You know it was bad when,
when,
uh,
when we had Charlie plumb and Jim Conkle on.
Yeah.
And I'm like thinking they're like,
you know,
hey,
this is the way to act.
Right.
And I'm like,
don't put me in that category with you guys.
You guys are awesome.
Like heroes and I'm just over here.
Yeah.
Don't say that about me.
You guys can say like,
Hey,
talk about character.
You have character.
I'm just over here trying to
shuck.
Next question should make map,
that's what we're calling McMath McMakin.
That's the Marine Corps martial arts program.
Should make map belts carry over in some way to Jujitsu built or should everyone
starts out as a white belt no matter what kind of training you've had before.
Yeah.
Yup.
White belt,
white belt.
Uh,
for those of you who don't know,
make map is Mick map is the Marine Corps martial arts program.
It's good program.
It's solid.
It's a solid good place to start.
The Marine Corps put together a good program.
The army has a really good program to the army combatives program.
Yeah.
Great stuff.
And both those are solid,
but specifically the Marine Corps makes when the Marine Corps martial arts
program has belts,
you get like a Tan belt and then I think a green belt and then a brown belt and
a black dog.
Pretty Legit,
right?
They have a little program.
Um,
there is no equivalency to Jujitsu.
Like you,
you'll know some stuff,
but it's,
you should just want to go to start to you to,
you just go with the white belt on.
I mean now it's the same thing with judo.
Judo is really close to Jujitsu as we know.
Judah is really close to Jitsu.
If you have a black belt in judo,
cool white belt in Jujitsu,
a sambo Severi,
you know,
again,
very similar to Jujitsu white belt.
So you might,
you're going to get promoted faster because you have a lot of experience in
wrestling is the same thing.
Like you just don't go,
Whoa,
I'm,
I'm uh,
I'm just going to show up as a purple belt cause I've been grappling for eight
years.
No,
it doesn't work that way.
Shell the white belt,
be humble.
No big deal.
You'll advance fast.
Don't care about the belts,
man.
We talk about this all the time.
Doesn't matter.
Just go in there and train.
And matter of fact,
having a white belt,
it's Kinda nice because there's no pressure whatsoever.
Like,
just enjoy that in,
enjoy,
not worried about getting tapped out.
Enjoy.
Just being able to roll and roll with people that are better than you or worse
than you.
And you're the lowest on the bottom of the totem pole.
You can roll with anybody in tap out and that's it.
It's cool.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah,
I agree.
Yeah.
I mean that seems kind of self explanatory maybe a little bit because you know,
it's like anything,
it's like any accolade cause it's really what the belt is essentially.
It's like an accolade,
right,
that you can wear.
I think that belt actually is a sign of where you are on the,
on the hierarchy.
Right.
And it's a sign though.
It's not written in stone.
It's just a sign.
Because we know that there's indicate yes.
An indicator.
Right.
Cause we know that there's,
there's,
there's the can tap out black belts and there's,
yeah.
And it's just an indicator.
But what about like the purpose though?
You know,
it's like a,
it's like a little thing,
like a badge.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure if I can counter that,
but I don't think,
yeah,
it's like a badge.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure it out for sure.
Like what it is.
I like belts by the way.
I like it.
I dig the whole thing.
Um,
but yeah,
if you get kind of that badge in,
in something specific,
it's only something specific.
Like even like real badges,
you know,
this is specific,
so yeah,
when you come and do something else,
it's like,
yeah,
you got to get that specific batch.
Yeah,
true in,
you know,
um,
studio five 40 right.
Rubs up there.
They have judo and Jiu Jitsu judo in there.
So,
you know,
if you're taking the Jujitsu class,
at noon and then you go to the judo class at two,
yeah.
You're changing your belts.
If you're different,
you know,
you can't just,
I'm just going to keep up my gear
and just teach me judo.
I'm not knowing and now obey you,
change your belts.
That's how you know,
this is a different thing.
And like he said,
it's vice versa to get your black belt in Jujitsu,
go to a judo class.
White Belt.
Yeah.
Straight up.
You're not,
he goes,
yeah.
Yeah.
But the actually this
question,
he said,
should it,
should it translate,
um,
carry over in some way.
Yeah.
It does carry over in some way,
right.
Have some level of skill.
The skill does not the belt though.
Yeah.
You have some level of skill.
Now,
if you're a black belt in mic map,
if all you took was Mick map,
you will not be able to,
you won't,
you will get you Ahmad,
have a good time.
You will not do well against,
uh,
a Jiu Jitsu black belt.
Most Jujitsu,
black belts.
Yeah.
You're not going to do well.
And that's,
and that's just kind of speaks more
time.
What time of training?
It's time of training.
If you've been training longer,
you're going to win.
Yeah.
That's the general rule.
You know,
of course there's athleticism and their strength and there's blah,
blah,
blah.
But if you've been training Jujitsu longer,
you're going to win.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
Next question.
I run a five man team,
two men down.
What does that mean?
It means these missing to you guys.
Okay,
so five man team.
So what?
It's supposed to be seven now with fiber it's,
it's a five man team.
Now there's only three.
We don't know either way.
We figured that he's undermanned.
Sure know.
Sure.
Okay.
Under man team five mentees to Minda.
I'm not meeting performance expectations,
no support coming from my command.
Do you see a way out other than just getting after it?
I know you also talk about blaming yourself in taking extreme ownership because
the people above you may have different information that leads to prioritize
different areas.
However,
when I questioned things like why we don't have enough people working in
different zones when clearly there's an imbalance in zones to the point
customers notice or it makes it difficult for colleagues to do their jobs,
then I'm deemed argumentative and that I don't have the best intentions.
This was,
this was with the manager that is in charge of in charge of business and I would
think understands my perspective more.
We're supposed to have a culture of feedback,
but he isn't receptive.
I'm not the only one who said that about him as well.
This all leads to me.
To me,
this all leads me to think that I must just be fake and go through the motions.
But that discussed.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
what do we do here?
How do we take ownership of this?
How do you take ownership of your boss not listening to you,
not hearing what you're saying?
Well,
the way you take ownership of that isn't to say my boss doesn't listen and
doesn't understand the way to take ownership.
But that is to say that I'm not a,
I'm not doing a good job of getting my information to my boss.
I'm not doing a good job of convincing my boss.
I'm not do a good job of influencing
my boss' boss.
So you can either be mad about that or you can change your approach.
Uh,
step one,
we're going back to this again today.
Um,
build a relationship with that person.
Now there's a chance that that discussed shield
there is,
right.
I've talked about that before.
I've literally said that I had great relationships with people that I had like a
visceral hatred for.
I still had a good relationship with them and worked very well with them.
If it discussed you and you can't do that,
then there's other jobs,
right?
We're going to have to interact with other people.
You know,
you can be like a long haul truck driver,
you can be a technical writer for you.
You know,
where you just look at the information and turn it into words.
You can be a lab technician.
We don't have to interact with a lot of different people and that's cool.
Um,
there's a lot of jobs out there that require very little human and action.
That's fine because if you think you're going to go through life only working
with people that you get along with,
you're wrong.
That's not going to happen.
Especially if you want to run teams and you want to lead and you have to learn
how to get over the fact that you might have to work with people that you don't
like.
And by the way,
on top of that,
if they know that you don't like them,
that is not going to make your job easier and it's Kinda not going to make your
life better.
In fact it's going to make your life more miserable.
The people that I had visceral hatred for that that I worked for,
it wasn't that bad because at least they thought I liked them and and I acted
like it and they liked me.
So it's like,
okay,
it was a little painful,
but you know what?
Yeah,
it's pretty low impact as opposed to like head to head conflict every single
day.
And by the way,
when you have head to head conflict every day you're miserable.
You're going to advance slower,
you're going to have less control over your fate,
you're not going to get promoted.
And on top of all that,
you're going to get assigned the crappiest possible jobs because your boss
doesn't like you and he likes that other guy over there.
So he's going to get the easy job.
Yeah,
right.
He's going to get go.
You go save the Princess Jocko,
go slay the dragon.
Right now,
of course we know,
I prefer to say the,
and it's never been the princess,
but that's what I'm saying,
like you want to get along with this person when to play the long game.
He wouldn't play the long game.
And here's the deal.
When you play the long game,
if the person's sucks as bad as you say they do,
they'll end up making their own bed and having to lie in it and they'll end up
working for you.
Now
also make sure that you come to the table with solutions,
not just complaints and problems,
right?
You could see that this guy's talking about we don't have enough guys and you
need to square with the zones.
Well,
what's your solution?
The problems and what's really smart to do,
and you've gotta be a little bit careful of this,
but what can be very smart to do is if you can solve the problem with your own
internal assets,
just go and execute on it and solve it.
It will.
If you use your own internal assets to solve a problem,
make the,
make the change,
make it happen to implement it.
And you go to the Boston,
say,
Hey,
this is what we did.
There was this problem on our zones or whatever.
The cool,
yeah,
we made this adjustment.
I took two guys from this,
blah,
blah.
I moved them around and now here's where we're at.
We're getting better.
You know,
results you,
you have to be careful because you can say that in such a way that you're thrown
in your boss's face,
right?
Yeah.
You can absolutely do that now.
Even though you were trying to build a relationship and trying to help the
mission and you still end up with an adversarial relationship with your boss.
And if things go negative again,
so you gotta be careful when you do this.
Or you can also just present the idea and present the solution and be like,
hey boss,
here's what I want to do.
Which is,
that's once you've got the relationship trust built up,
that doesn't there,
that you can't just go present a broad present a solution of how you're going to
do it.
It's not gonna let you do it because he doesn't trust you.
Yeah.
He's got an adversarial relationship with you.
You see where this is?
Yeah.
You see how this works?
Another thing he says in here,
he says,
uh,
I would think the manage,
this was a manager that is in charge of the business.
And I would think he understands my perspective more,
right?
So here we go.
If you want to take ownership of things and how you,
and you look at your boss and say,
he doesn't blame my perspective or doesn't understand my perspective,
that's his fault.
You know,
the way I look at that,
if you don't understand my perspective as my boss,
it's my fault.
That means I'm not explaining to you.
It means I'm not giving you enough information means I'm not convinced you.
It means I'm not building relationships so that you can see my perspective.
That's what that is.
So don't blame the boss.
Step up your game.
Build the relationship.
Teach him the perspective and a win.
And I'll tell you one more little thing on this from a,
to get away from the disgust mindset because I understand that.
Yeah.
You know,
the one,
one good way to get away from disgust mindset is to get into the game mindset.
The game,
like this is a game and this guy that I don't like,
I'm going to become best friends with them.
Watch me like,
okay,
oh you don't like this guy?
Cool.
Watch.
Yeah,
watch this.
That's how it's gonna go and you're going to find with it,
are you going to try and win the game?
Yeah.
Which is good.
I'm sure
that understanding perspective,
um,
I think that's the everyday,
almost everyday kind of thing where,
okay,
so my wife,
we're on our way to the park.
This is today by the way.
And she's like,
oh it,
she said it's,
there's two parks,
there's one,
you can go straight.
There's one,
you'd make a right.
Then you make another left isn't,
there's two parks and I don't know which one are we going to,
I don't really mind which one we go to.
Uh,
so she was like,
yeah,
let's,
let's go to the other one.
Right.
And she mentions the,
I dunno,
which even one is the other one,
but whatever.
I'll follow your direction.
So she said,
okay,
make her said she goes,
stay this lane.
She doesn't motion though.
She goes stay in this lane something.
Okay,
we're going to stay in this lane.
And she goes,
okay turn here.
But then so she's not like pointing like turn here.
It's like,
cause there's a turn right here and then there's one like right here,
you know,
turn here can apply to like a bunch of stuff.
But in her mind it's super clear,
you know?
So if I would've got mad or actually the,
I can see how people can get frustrated right there.
Right.
So if I were to express myself,
oh you're not being more clear.
Boom.
Now we're,
we're against each other because I didn't,
in my mind I'm like,
I can't read your mind.
Explain better.
Just got a funny story.
He was,
they were on night visions in a Humvee is telling the driver,
he's in the vehicle commander seat,
which is the,
basically the pat the front passenger seat and he's,
he's pointing,
he's going,
hey,
turn here,
here,
here.
And,
and the guy just keeps driving and he goes,
Bro redoing and the guy's like,
I can't see you because we have night vision goggles on.
You have no peripheral vision.
He's like,
I can't see your fingers.
And leaves like,
oh sorry.
Because what you can probably call his right turn 30 meters.
Right,
right turn 500 meters.
Right.
Turn a hundred meters right.
Turn coming up.
Right turn,
boom.
And that way the person can do it.
Yeah.
But life was pointing but the guy couldn't say,
but there's this very similar to your wife who's not pointing.
Yeah,
she wasn't pointed at the time.
Well,
here's the thing too.
This is jammed me up.
I'm not to take too long in this one,
but the way girls,
girl,
the way girls,
female females,
girls take,
do you remember the last time you talked about you generalize females?
Go ahead at your peril.
Go ahead.
No,
he wasn't in my parole because that,
that was the same thing.
It was the giant of bicycling.
Exactly right.
It's the same thing.
Cause then Nolan,
Nolan,
jewel bike,
it's completely cut her off to correct someone.
Drew you on a trace on animated just as legit credit separate than the plane.
But it was good.
There was also some,
there was also some pretty a nonworking bicycles that were drawn.
Correct.
And I dig it and this is by no means says you know,
the superiority or inferiority of any of this,
of the sex at all.
I'm just saying there was a study done,
girls and guys interpret and give directions in completely different ways
because of how they,
how their brain formulates like um,
like uh,
directions.
So girls kind of required,
this is real.
Generally speaking,
girls are required like landmark Jordan B.
Peterson back on the talk about this.
Okay.
I want to,
I'd ask.
So girls,
they prefer like landmarks and you know,
you know,
like the voice on the thing like she'll be like,
oh,
and this one so they can wait.
You mean the Siri Voice?
Siri voice?
Yeah,
whatever,
whatever.
Yeah.
I mean those can help guys to or whatever that that navigation voice wasn't part
of this study so I shouldn't even mention the voice.
But they prefer like landmarks,
like maker rights and resting in a building jet.
Yeah.
When,
when you're flying a jet plane.
Sure.
Yeah.
Which,
which I have done a backseat ride into f 18 before,
but the voice that talks to you is a,
is a female voice and the,
and I was told that it's because it relaxes,
it gets the attention of and then kinda relaxes the pilots.
So it says like,
like when I was fine and I dunno,
I wasn't like we were going to die,
but um,
at all,
like I'm not going to say that at all.
But the thing would say warning,
it was a girl's voice from take warning,
warning,
altitude,
altitude and yeah.
So they say it's relaxing a little bit.
Yeah,
I could dig it.
Um,
you know,
typically if my wife has given me directions,
it's not relaxing.
I'm not saying it's stressful,
but it's not relaxing.
So where were you going with this new girl that you said was going to be
shorter?
It's dangerous to do the directions thing,
the navigation thing with your wife or your girlfriend or with the girl?
With the girl.
Then like if you,
let's say you and a girl in whatever capacity is sitting next to you and you
guys are,
you know how like one we're looking for the hotel and we were both sort of
looking for the hotel and we're both kind of navigating and then I failed.
Then you just jumped me.
You don't remember that.
You actually debrief me.
You're like hey,
when it was time,
when I failed that math,
you were just like,
I got this here.
Right.
Turn coming up 500 meters.
Right turn 200 meters.
Yeah,
right turn 100 meters.
Right turn right turn right turn.
Okay,
get the right hand lane.
And you were just like cool.
Yeah.
Yes.
So it's easy.
So consider that type of situation before you took over.
Consider that situation when we were both trying to navigate.
If you do that with a girl you,
you are more likely to run into problems because of this.
They interpret know what this is and how they interpret and give directions in
different ways cause their brain works different.
They require it like landmarks got kinda guide them.
Okay.
Make a right at this,
make a left at this.
That helps.
Sure.
But it's more the guys go off of,
they build the map in their head.
So if they're like,
okay,
like if they looked at a map they'd be like,
they'd have a better understanding.
Okay so sure I can make a right at the,
at the building or whatever.
But when they make a right there like okay I made that right.
So here I am physically oriented,
you know,
and they kind of make sense of that way more than the girls do.
I'm not saying there's like one is black,
one is white.
I'm seeing w one does one,
one does more than,
yeah,
it's more than 10 tendency because it's how your mind works.
Okay.
This is just the start.
I didn't do the study at any way to address this with echo on social media can
address it to echo.
I'm out.
I will say this and I'll believe the study.
I sure will cause I haven't been.
The other one is if you have it,
if you can listen to all the podcasts.
Echo also said that girls cannot draw off hand a functional bicycle.
Correct.
And he got a lot.
He got a lot of attempts.
Yeah.
And he did get one person that put a gift.
It's a gift for animated Gif,
animated Gif of echo himself riding a tricycle icicle.
Yeah.
It was pretty awesome.
Again,
beside the point,
but it was very awesome.
I don't even
have any idea what the point of anything that we've said in the last few
minutes,
and I don't even want you to try and explain to about miscommunication.
Like,
I can't read your mind.
You've got a community,
you know,
like the heat don't understand my perspective he's supposed to understand kind
of thing.
You know God.
Yes,
yes.
True,
true men.
So you gotta be clear.
This is what I'm saying,
like how you were when we were finding that steak place or the hotel or whatever
else.
A good steak,
by the way.
Yes.
All right.
Next question.
Do you think we,
do you think you would take up Jujitsu in your forties if you had been
introduced to something else in your 20s like Muy Thai boxing,
et Cetera?
I'm struggling with Jujitsu.
I respect the hell out of it.
I have an easier time with boxing and kickboxing.
Just interesting.
I'm just making a little bit like I have an easier time with these things.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
So that's what I'm going to focus on.
Maybe giving your most recent admission that you're,
you are boring.
Obviously you're not because of your popularity.
Do you think you'd pick it up later in life?
Jujitsu to me is a chore.
Boxing kickboxing is fun.
I think because in my youth I figured out how to move my body in that way.
I'm 43,
by the way.
Uh,
so first of all,
do I think I would go to Jujitsu or started Jujitsu or get into Jujitsu in my
forties if I hadn't,
if I had been?
Yes,
absolutely.
100%.
Uh,
the power of Jujitsu is very real.
It's a real thing.
And once I recognized it,
I wanted to have that power.
The power to
choke people are walk them dominate when like when with no mercy.
Now what,
What's interesting about this is there's certain people like certain things,
right?
And he even says like,
I have an easier time with kickboxing and boxing cause he's,
he's part of,
that's because he's done it for a long time since it's 20.
So it's just easy for him and [inaudible] like Jujitsu seems like a chore for
Him.
Cause you know what else he's getting beat up,
you know,
if he doesn't just get into it now he's getting beat up.
He's getting sure out.
That's a chore,
man.
It's hard.
It's hard on the ego.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I thought of an interesting rule.
If you don't like Jujitsu,
if you don't think you liked you,
maybe,
what do you think of this rule?
If you don't think you like Jujitsu,
take it.
And I was trying to think of,
take it for six months,
take it for three months.
And I said take it until you legitimately submit someone that is comparable in
some way to you.
Yeah.
You think that's a good rule?
I think that's a good rule.
Yeah,
that's a good rule.
Yeah.
Because I'm not talking about you.
You tap someone out that's weak and small,
are weaker than you and smaller than you,
and then you're like,
see,
I can tap out.
I'm going to quit now.
No,
I'm talking about someone that's equivalent to someone that has some comparable
like physical attributes to you,
because I believe that once somebody gets the
taste of the power power,
and also this is also implies,
or is it factually,
if you train enough that you submit someone,
that means you got submitted thousands,
probably 500 times.
You think that's a good number five.
I bet if you,
by the time you submit what someone in Jujitsu,
you've probably been submitted 500 times.
Okay.
400 ten three hundred times.
300 times,
yeah.
Yeah.
If you go to Jujitsu academy as a white belt,
the zero training you're going to get submitted
four times,
five times,
six times a class.
Right.
Well,
it just depends if there's other white belts that are first,
second,
third,
fourth,
fifth day for the first month.
So he you could now,
yeah.
You could depend on and that you get it submitted.
Oh yeah.
Times 300 times.
Its 200 times.
It's definitely more than a hundred but I wouldn't say before a hundred times in
a week.
Wait,
before he was Dee Dee said times before you tap over to anybody.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's going to depend.
If you have other white belt in first day guys,
let's say you've,
yeah,
of course you've been training for three weeks.
You can tap out something that hasn't been training app.
Yeah.
That's how fast you can learn Jujitsu.
When I first,
the first moves that I learned,
I didn't,
I probably knew like a month's worth of Jujitsu,
but no one could hang with me because I knew like the basic stuff and no one
even knew what to do.
Yeah,
yeah.
Consider a rear naked choke.
All you have to do is you can learn the rear naked choke one day in the
beginning of class and all you have to figure out when you roll.
If a guy doesn't have much experience,
all you have to figure out is how to get on his back.
It's all you got to do is really cool when you teach kids Jujitsu,
like you can say something like,
you could give them the class on how to pass the guard.
Yeah.
Right.
And they would start to do what you told them to do.
Or You could say,
okay,
your goal is to get out of their legs and get around,
uh,
and they'll figure out how to do it and it's pretty awesome.
And then what you do is you give him a couple little planers yeah.
Because their instincts will be a little bit off,
but you come a couple little pointers,
a couple of things to work with and then they'll develop those into some really
cool stuff.
Yeah.
I don't know if I said this before,
but that even is true.
Not as much,
but it's still true with adults because if you teach them the technique first
and then,
then you say,
hey,
the those techniques that taught you,
that's passing the garden and it doesn't,
it's way easier to like get,
it's almost like getting a big piece of clay and being like,
okay,
make the head,
make the body,
make the arms.
That's it.
And then be like,
okay,
now you got the arms.
That's cool.
Now I'll make the fingers now,
make the,
you know,
and then start to go with the details there as far as the technical techniques
with like passing the guard.
But I,
that's how actually that's how I learned from Dean where he would teach stuff.
But I would just see him like getting past and I know,
okay,
when he gets passed to you,
that's like hard to get out of.
So that's what I wanted to try to do and when guys would get this affirmative.
Yeah.
So I thought,
I thought that it really worked better that way to just to teach that way if
someone's starting from zero,
because it's hard to put into context when you don't know anything.
You're like,
yeah,
I'm doing this cool lights.
Pretty cool.
Neat.
It's cool doing the intro class at the monster because you have a lot of people
that have never done did you two before?
Yeah.
And that's that the cow and how you're saying to teach is exactly how we teach
them the text.
Like,
Hey,
this is the concept.
And then we teach a couple little moves of like what to do there.
And then you watch people get after it and they do get it.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah.
But yes,
here,
the,
the reason for this,
and this goes for anything,
by the way,
if you are successful,
especially if they're all,
if they're kind of similar,
like in this case where he's like,
okay,
martial arts,
right?
Jujitsu,
I'm going to start Jujitsu way late.
Meanwhile,
I have experience doing when we timeboxing so if he has experience,
assuming he's been somewhat successful,
not necessarily competition but not not competition,
just so he knows what he's doing.
When he throws a punch,
he can have a level of success of that punch landing,
you know like,
and it's going to be pretty often if he has 20 years experience,
give or take,
whatever.
So he's experiencing little,
how should I say,
a little micro successes when he jumps in the boxing situation and we tight and
you just use getting no failure,
micro failures all day,
all day.
It's a huge chore and that's life.
So if you look,
if you're,
if you're going in with nothing,
you have no micro,
you know,
success is no nothing.
You're just going in.
I don't train anything.
I go in,
sure I'll take some hits,
I'll take some failures because I'm learning this new thing.
But if you have it compared to,
look,
I'm going to come into victory MMA,
I'm going to see the kickboxing situation going on and said,
you Jitsu situation quite on my brain is automatically going to be like,
okay,
what's going to be the best experience for me or any victories?
If I'm going to go where the victories are,
I'm going to go where the payoff is.
You know those payoffs where I can land punches,
I can do it,
I can know what I'm dulling.
Dang.
When I moved my body,
it does what I want it to do and it yields success.
Yeah,
it's effective.
Or I can go to Jujitsu and where everyone else has success.
Everyone else is getting their payoff,
not me.
By the way,
everyone else is.
I'm getting tapped out.
And that part in and of itself is like,
that's,
especially if you're a guidance,
is it a personality thing where some people,
as soon as they get,
as soon as they get tapped into just pseudo like,
oh my God,
I need to learn this immediately.
Like,
you know when you're young people get the Jujitsu bug.
Yeah,
sure.
everyone else did.
You do to book,
right?
Not everyone.
A lot of people do.
Well,
what percentage of people get the Jujitsu book?
Dang,
I have no 20% 30% depends.
Like 20% of who?
Of all people.
It was probably not even 20% think about it like it's weird as much as theirs
there is Jujitsu as much as we talk about it in a very positive way.
People,
normal people have a hard time with it.
It's weird for me to admit that.
It's weird for me to say that B,
but if I think about it,
I've talked about this before,
like of all the people that I've introduced to Jujitsu over the years,
I,
I think I have like maybe four black belts of people that I fully like they,
they started,
you did too because of me.
I'm talking so that with those percentages,
it's a very,
very small people that actually stick with it and get the bug might not even
before and,
but you and you can get the bug and the bug kind of wear off.
You know?
That is where,
you know,
I,
I remember then that's not the bug.
That's not the real bugs.
That's like the,
the,
the Diet bug light.
Well,
it's a bug light because people gets purple belt and then they don't show up
anymore.
People that the brown belt,
they don't show up.
People don't get the blue belt and they don't show up anymore.
Yeah.
It just,
they just keep training.
Yeah.
Basket blog.
That's the real bug fully.
I used to think like,
when you dream about it,
you know how like your dream,
you'll learn the move and you'll dream.
It'll just be kind of be a new thing in your mind.
You know?
It's the conscious and the subconscious.
I thought that that was kind of it,
but in my experience that that goes away sometimes.
It depends on what you're into,
but I dunno.
Yeah.
But nonetheless,
he,
that's it.
That's what I think.
Cause that's pretty common.
Like
actual advice.
Yeah.
Like do you think you think that's so my answers are yes.
I would have stunned Jujitsu cause I would have had the bug and my advice is if
it's a chore,
keep doing it until it's fun.
Yeah,
I get it.
It is fun to get beat.
It's fun to get like it's fun.
It's fun to have like my favorite people to train with other people that gave me
the hardest runs,
absolute most favorite people to train with other people that actually can get
me,
you know.
But it's again,
when you have to have this,
there's this third factor here where the kickboxing and boxing is right there.
I could be right there right now.
Meaning you know,
just doing it and,
but I'm not,
I'm over here and this guy's mounted on me and he's been,
he's choking me and stuff like it's man,
it's,
I date it and then it makes it,
I guess we could reverse this question.
Say like,
okay Jocko then when,
why,
why aren't you in boxing and striking all the time.
For me that's a pretty,
it's actually not that hard of an answer.
I've done boxing and stroking.
And the thing that is different is inboxing and striking.
Even though you're talking about Mike Rowe wins most of the nights of training,
boxing or kickboxing there,
the micro winds are against pads and a bag.
Right?
Cause you're not sparring every night.
And if you are sparring every night,
you're,
you're making a mistake and you're not even going as hard as in,
you're not going comparatively.
I mean,
you can have fun.
And we,
we do that too.
Like we call it playing tag where you're like,
you're like touching the person.
You're,
you're,
it's almost like a slap fight,
you know?
But you can't do that ever.
You can't spar every night and you shouldn't spar every night.
And if you are a sparring every night,
you're wrong.
But you can roll every night.
You can get,
you can get full victories,
not micro victories,
full submissions.
So yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
And I agree.
And I think that if you
did say it really depends on who you are,
but to me that was the,
the,
the big time appeal and still is the legitimate appeal of Jujitsu where,
you know,
how like people even now they'll be like,
hey,
but this martial arts is superior because this and that.
But really Jujitsu's kind of being tested the best because it's point against
an enemy,
quote unquote enemy who's trying to,
it's funny when people are like,
how would you ever get someone's arm there?
You know what I mean?
We were like,
Oh yeah,
you get the good,
eat that on lock.
Try that on me.
It's like,
oh,
okay,
cool.
Yeah.
I'm gonna say just reading about it didn't,
um,
Gordon Ryan just beat somebody he like called it.
Yeah.
He called it [inaudible] seven.
He was like,
I'm going to beat you with this.
And he did it within this amount of time.
Did it that slide away.
Yeah.
And that's how it is men.
And that's against a high level guy.
What Gordon Ryan's obviously one of the best guys right now.
Um,
but that,
that is kind of how would you do to is,
you know,
unless it's like some,
that's huge giant football player,
just spasming and writing away the whole time.
If you're in someone's engaging you,
that's kind of how it is.
Where you're like,
oh,
I can choke if they don't know.
Do you get to,
and you know it's like,
yeah,
oh yeah,
for sure.
They're like,
how are you going to get my arm there?
And Ryan did not do that to someone that didn't know Jujitsu.
I know some funny cause that's those,
those,
the Hixson stories,
you know,
like Hixson would be like,
I'm going to every,
all of you 14 black belts,
I'm going to arm lock your left arm,
all of you.
And He'd do it.
All of them black belts.
Yeah.
Damn.
You heard those stories,
right?
Yeah,
I rolled with Hixon.
I've talked about that before.
Yeah.
Hixon is really good at Jujitsu.
Sure.
Yeah.
But yes,
but I don't know though.
So what do you do though?
Like what,
what's the,
what's the advice back to the,
my advice is say,
like I said,
that's why I think my new rule is train until you submit someone that is
legitimately comparable to you and then if you don't like it still then don't
train.
Like I,
there was one guy on social media that like kept coming back to me.
Like I know I hate Jujitsu.
I hate it,
I hate it.
And I was like,
after awhile I'm like,
okay,
can you defend yourself against,
you know,
I take down,
can you get up from the bottom?
Okay.
Didn't go find something else to do and quit complaining to me about it.
Like everyone is not meant for Jujitsu.
I get it.
It's fine.
Yeah.
I almost,
but it's still is beneficial though.
Feels like it is for,
it's what it feels like.
That's what it feels like.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what it feels like to you and me and to the people that we hang out with.
And that's why when I was saying like some people don't like Jujitsu is really
weird for me to understand that I have a hard time with their perspective.
That's fully Mr. Mr Understand their perspective and you tell me like I don't
really liked your did so it's like a why?
Why would you not like it?
Straight up.
I'm glad you don't like it makes life easier for me.
One person I don't have to worry about being able to choke me for sure.
Okay.
I would say this,
try this.
If you're in this situation,
this is what I would do.
Try to forget about like when you're like,
okay,
I'm gonna go do Jujitsu tonight.
Forget about boxing as a concept.
Forget about kickbox,
forget about it.
Like don't,
don't think about that.
Do you like your whole thing right now is like is just Jujitsu and learn or
think of it as like just this complete learning experience of course,
but forget about the boxing because anytime like that's hot,
that's what's going to happen.
When you keep that boxing on your mind or the kickboxing on your mind,
you're like,
why am I doing this when I could be doing boxing,
which was like bad ass anyway.
You know,
kind of thing,
but just forget about it.
Yeah.
I think that's the thing.
You know how like guys in the UFC that'll,
that'll happen sometimes where they're super good at Jujitsu and then they'll
train boxing aids and it's vice versa too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like I was just saying like some people,
and this is true with fighters to some fighters don't like striking.
They don't like to get hit specifically.
No one minds punching people.
Some people like it,
some people like they,
they truly liked to punch someone else in the head.
Some people are good with it.
Most people are good with it cause it feels good.
Some people don't like to get hit.
They really don't like that.
Some people don't like to get smashed on the ground.
They get claustrophobic,
right?
They don't like that.
And so different people have little different,
I don't know if calm weaknesses but preferences.
And you can see that very clearly,
especially in the earlier you fcs nowadays you're not getting the UFC if you're
super uncomfortable in,
in any arena of martial arts,
if you're just,
if you're just super uncomfortable,
stand up.
You,
you,
you know,
maybe you might make an undercard barely,
but you don't see that on TV.
You don't go as far for sure.
There you go.
I like that rule.
Do it until you tap someone else who's like,
I'm legit comparable to you.
Cause,
cause what I think happens once you do that and you're like,
oh I want to do badly.
Yeah.
And you got the benefit of getting tapped out,
which is a bet,
which to me motivates me more than just happened.
Someone out.
Yeah.
Like how did someone control me?
Think about that in another human being can control me completely.
Dean those that to me sometimes,
and I'm sitting here thinking to myself,
I'm like,
man,
I've been training for a really long time and I'm a grown man in good physical
condition,
relatively strong.
And he can cold me in a position where I cannot do anything and I can actually
do that to him too.
Not as clearly,
not as often,
but he's got,
he's got three physicians,
he can do it to me and I think he can cross side mount
and on all force.
Right.
If I'm in one of those positions or he's one of those positions on me,
the I'm doomed.
I deal for me,
it's only,
I don't have a mount on him,
but his mountain scape is awesome and my mounts not really good,
so he's,
he can get out of that.
So it's no big deal,
but cross eyed or when he's on all fours,
I'm going to torture him and we both know we're going to get tortured in those
positions for him.
It's too busy for him.
He,
there's two positions he's going to get tortured him for me,
there's three positions I'm gonna get tortured,
tortured,
tortured.
Yes,
sir.
I would agree.
You've seen it.
It's torture.
Yeah.
You felt it too.
Both the examples,
all exam.
I can escape,
escape,
but yeah.
No,
that's bad.
I dig it.
That isn't that weird though.
You have,
you know,
25 over 25 years experience,
train very strong and big by the way,
like compared to like a normal Jujitsu guy.
Like you're a big Europe thing.
That huge play Jujitsu player,
big strong experience.
Know what to do,
know what not to do all that doesn't mean anything guest for that moment doesn't
mean nothing yet.
Holy Cow.
That's a scary thing.
Yeah.
Next question.
Good evening.
I'm a firefighter paramedic and I'm still the rookie yet my station,
the fire service is notorious for politics within the ranks and rookies often
get the worst of it.
My question is,
how can I implement extreme ownership in a situation where the blame falls to me
anyway,
how can I have my superiors view this as a positive trait when every Ruki gets
the short end of the stick and when none of my superiors are willing to engage
in extreme ownership,
I'm taking ownership.
However,
the typical response along is along the lines of,
that's correct.
It is your fault to hey,
yeah.
You know what?
That's correct.
It is your fault.
That's what extreme ownership is.
That's what it is.
Okay?
That's what extreme ownership it is.
You're saying it's your fault.
You're not just saying it so they leave you alone.
You're saying it because you're taking ownership of it.
Then you can fix what is wrong.
That's what it is.
So I will tell you,
the boss will notice.
He will,
he'll notice,
and the people above you in the chain of command will notice.
They will notice that you are taking ownership.
Now notice that you're solving problems.
I notice that that will then give you a good reputation,
but taking extreme ownership does not absolve you of the blame.
That's the opposite of that.
Yeah,
you are at fault.
That's the whole point.
And this is one of those classic questions I get asked all the time.
It's like,
what if they say the,
if they see right,
it is your fault.
That's what you're saying.
Yeah.
So it doesn't matter.
It's true in business,
it's,
and it's true in life too.
If you're blaming other people for things that are going wrong,
you're not going to fix them.
You can't fix them because in your mind you don't control them.
They're not your fault.
So if you want to take extreme ownership at work and in business and in stop
blaming other people and blame yourself and realize that it actually is your
fault at that,
correct.
Own it and do something about it.
But
do you think that sometimes I'm like this,
you know how some people will at like at the muster,
some people say that ask you this and they'll say,
it'll be similar to this where there'll be like,
like I'm trying to take extreme ownership,
but you know,
something like this happens and then you say,
well,
yeah,
like you take extreme ownership,
you actually take the blame and then you talk about how you're going to fix the
problem,
right?
Like that's how you know you don't just take,
do you don't say,
yes,
my fault and then boom,
we're good,
we're done my bus kind of thing.
That's ego.
It's funny because your ego is like,
if I say like echo,
this went wrong and it's my fault and then you go,
yeah,
you should have done a better job.
I get that.
That's my defense.
I'm like,
oh,
what are you talking about?
Well,
you know,
I,
I would have been able to do it better if you have done blah,
blah,
blah.
So even though I'm saying I'm taking ownership,
I'm not actually taking ownership.
So that was actually going to be my question.
Uses people.
So it's almost like maybe it all the time,
but it's almost like,
like let's say I did something and I messed up,
I caught my own mistake right in the middle of the day and I was like,
man,
I'm so dumb.
And it was a domestic with,
oh,
I'm so dumb.
And you said,
yeah,
you are a dumpmen and be like,
wait,
don't call me dumb.
Right.
It's kind of like that,
right?
It's like,
man,
you just said you're dumb.
I think,
you know what else is funny is to,
as you hear people make excuses,
like,
uh,
but instead of taking the blame,
instead of taking,
owning the excuse that they,
so like let's say,
uh,
I wasn't prepared for a podcast or let's say no,
I said,
hey,
we're going to,
we can try and record on Wednesday,
but I don't think I'm gonna be able to do it because I have this going on in my
dog did this and my kid did that and I'm,
I'm making excuses.
Instead of saying like,
Hey,
I didn't plan well enough and I didn't anticipate some things that I should have
anticipated and now I'm not going to be ready.
Right?
Yeah.
It's my fault.
Now,
if you get what this is,
what happens,
and this is the difference,
man,
if you have the habit of actually saying like,
Hey,
I didn't anticipate this and it's actually my fault,
then you know what you do,
you plan better.
Yeah.
How many times have I called you up and said,
hey,
echo,
I'm not ready to record the podcast a few times.
No,
actually no.
You said,
I might not be ready,
and then he got mad at yourself.
Yeah,
got mad,
but I was actually giving you a warning of like,
Hey,
I'm going to be,
it's going to be tight,
but I knew I was going to have to work to try and get it done.
What I'm saying is when you truly say like everything that's happening in my
world is my fault,
you don't make excuses anymore upfront.
You,
you,
any ring a you do.
You say like,
Hey,
here's what's going on and this is what I'm going to do to get over to them.
Yeah.
It's a big difference,
man.
It has a huge impact when you're saying here's a good one.
I like,
this is one of them.
Probably the most common thing of anything,
any excuse is I don't have time.
That's the most.
Is there any more common excuse that I don't have time besides the dog ate my
homework,
right.
I don't.
Not that I know of.
No.
By the way,
one time the dog literally ate my kid's homework.
It was all chewed up like,
well I'll get your homework,
keep your,
keep your ena dog secure area.
So there's no ego,
there's no bigger excuse that gets used more common at least for like a long
term goal.
Like,
Hey,
I want to do you name it,
I want to go on to play piano and I play guitar,
I want to write a book,
I want to just study,
I want to get my degree,
all this stuff.
Right.
Anything is just,
I don't have to,
I want to get in shape.
Right.
I want to run everyday.
It's all,
hey,
even even I want to spend more time with my kids,
but I have time.
Yeah.
So that's the,
that's the pre given excuse.
But when you blame all these other things,
the time,
it's not your fault that you don't have time.
It's the fault of the schedule.
It's the fault of the,
whether it's the fault of,
it's the lack of time.
The fact of the matter is if you take ownership of that,
if you take ownership of the time,
you will have time.
Cause you'll make time.
Yeah.
And when I call you up and say,
Hey,
I might not be able to get ready what I'm doing.
It's like saying,
okay,
I'm giving him a warning and then I'm looking at my schedule going,
where can I finish prep?
Or where can I prepare for this?
Yeah.
When can I get this done?
That's the ultimate excuse for so many people.
I don't have time.
And the minute you say that you don't have control over the time you do have
control over the time,
guess what?
Hey,
are there people that are working three jobs?
Yes,
there are.
And might they have,
are there things that are going to have to edit out of their schedule?
Yes.
There are one of the first things you should edit out of your schedule.
Youtube,
Social Media,
Surfing,
Internet surfing,
right.
Uh,
what else did we do to waste time?
You know what I mean?
Like we wasted time doing things TV,
so that way if you,
if you haven't,
excuse s turn it back on yourself and take control of it.
That's all I'm saying.
We got you.
Make the time.
Yeah.
Little set time saving element.
I don't even know if it's a tip.
It's just a little thing to consider when you cruise cruise extra hard so you
can get it done in half the time.
I'm disciplined with my time.
So like Ken crew sometimes discipline equals cruising.
Yes.
That's the freedom part of increasing the time is like a,
it can be kind of like a balloon with like little leaks in it where you know you
want to like time we'll just kind of leak away.
Right?
So if you're not,
you know how like I think you were the one who kind of told me where he's like
you should eat,
shouldn't like plan kind of everything.
You got to go,
just plan it all and get it done.
And then the rest of that time is all is you're typing free.
Yeah.
So if you're like,
okay,
I have some stuff to do today but I'm not going to plan it necessarily.
I'm just going to sort of get it done tomorrow.
At some point you could get one thing done,
you could just be,
you know,
messing around and whatever and then you get another thing done and you kind of
like,
Dang,
that took me kind of all day.
A lot of times when,
you know,
especially if you have like three or four things,
but all those like little in between times if you can add them all up.
But sure.
Okay.
Workout takes,
let's say you really want to go hard and say,
I want to work off for an hour and a half every day,
but I don't really have a free hour and a half in a row.
Right?
Because I've got to go pick up my kids and I've got to go do this.
I got to drop them off.
I had to do all this stuff.
But if most of the time,
if you're like,
okay,
I'm going to schedule all these things and I'm gonna pump them and get them all
done,
then it's almost like you're,
you're shifting your time so it doesn't just leak through the,
the little things that you have to do when you allow it to.
I think it was you that originally talked about this.
How much work do people get done before like vacation?
Like they know where they're going on vacation.
Same Way I
do that every day.
Yes.
More free time.
Yeah.
Just even like when you're leaving,
had this sort of found myself,
I did this the other day.
I went,
I actually went to 24 hour fitness,
got a good word compiler.
So I went to,
Jennifer was got my workout or whatever,
came out and came in my truck.
I was checking,
checking the crypto stuff,
but so I got my truck checked it and I was checking it in,
in like check some other alerts,
you know,
check in and boom,
boom.
And then I,
and then I left.
So I remember when I put my phone down and I started it up and I left.
I kind of looked over it and you could see the window of 24 hour fitness and you
know,
the people that work at the front desk are there.
So I,
for whatever reason,
I'm thinking to myself,
I wonder if they were watching me like,
oh,
another person addicted to his phone in there.
Kind of just had that thought.
You know,
I thought about,
I was like,
wait there.
That was like a good maybe 10 minutes that I just like let leak away right
there.
Hey,
if,
if that was part of my schedule,
if I needed to check these things for sure.
I couldn't like if that was on some sort of a schedule or if I choose,
if I chose to do that at a specific time,
I would've got that 10 minutes back somehow.
Like that 10 minutes when the leak to it.
No,
I actually,
by the time he's left the gym at that particular time,
if I didn't let that 10 minutes,
I would've been home already doing other stuff that I should have.
Schedules.
Yeah,
work doing it.
exactly right and we do that all day.
That kind of stuff.
Don't let your time,
but another thing,
we're another time more or another situation where this works.
What you were saying about this,
I'm taking ownership in for real take ownership.
Don't be like,
Hey,
you know,
oh it's my fault.
And then they said it's your fault and be like,
Ooh,
what are the ones who was white ball kind of thing.
I'm not saying he said that,
but I'm saying that is apologizing when you apologize to someone you don't like.
Someone's like,
Hey,
hey,
look,
look mean you had a disagreement,
escalated,
whatever.
Then the next day I'm like,
Hey man,
I'm sorry you but,
but you did kind
of say something,
you know,
but I,
but I am sorry.
You know kind of thing.
Yeah.
Right.
So you're putting a ball in there and you're like,
it's not real.
It's not a true apology.
It's not affective at all like you.
Or if you explain like,
but I was just feeling this or you know,
it's just,
you know,
anytime there's not a like a full on 100% full speed apology towards someone.
Like don't mention the reasons why you felt that way.
Don't mention any kind of justification on why you went there with your mind,
who,
whatever.
It's all just like,
this is what it did is all like terrible and whatever.
And I'm straight up.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Speaking of apologies,
next question.
I'm sorry for taking so long with that and you know,
but you were really egging me on.
I'm just saying.
Next question Jocko.
The military taught me to never apologize.
Speaking to which because it's a sign of weakness,
had a conversation with a coworker who says that extreme ownership is the same
as apologizing.
So,
uh,
first of all,
no apologizing is actually not a sign of weakness.
And whoever was putting that out,
whoever taught that was actually too insecure about themselves and their
leadership capability to admit when they were wrong or made a mistake and,
and really insecure about a lot of other things,
most likely people,
it's actually the opposite.
People that can't admit their mistakes are weak.
And people that can't apologize when they screw up our week,
they're scared.
They're scared to take ownership and they're protective of their ego.
Now,
that being said,
extreme ownership is not the same as apologizing,
but they're definitely similar.
You know,
extreme ownership means you're admitting that there's some kind of a problem and
you're taking ownership of that problem.
If it's something that you did wrong,
then you're,
you're taking ownership of that mistake.
The key part,
as you already said,
is not that you're just owning the problem.
You're actually solving the problem.
And Yeah,
if you screw something up or you make a mistake,
then apologize for it,
apologize for your shortfalls,
and then you can move forward.
Uh,
Sarah Armstrong,
she's set a couple times on Twitter when I'm said like,
yeah,
say you're sorry.
She said ask for forgiveness too.
I haven't,
I haven't tried that one out,
but she seems to see,
seems to think that that is another,
and when she says things,
I listened to her.
She's smart.
I won't look,
we talked about that.
I think it might've been Sarah Armstrong.
Oh wait,
she said that a long time ago.
Long.
Okay.
Yeah.
You see,
we've talked about this before.
And here's my take on that one.
Say it again.
I'm not 100% on that one.
Well,
you asked for forgiveness.
This is why,
because it's this.
If someone,
I dig it as far as like doing it,
it feels like it does feel like a,
like a humble kind of approach,
but it can be taken like this.
So I would take it and I don't think I'd be most of the time
where when it's like,
okay,
I'm,
I'm sorry,
you know,
I'm,
I messed up.
It's all me or whatever.
Right?
So it's almost like he,
you throw the ball in their court to be the bad guy.
It's kind of like,
so it's a,
it's almost like a guaranteed way to get forgiven.
That's what it is.
And it's kind of like,
I know that.
So it was like,
this is me strong arming forgiveness from you.
It's like shaming you into forgiveness.
So you're saying if you're like,
if I say,
Hey Echo,
I'm really sorry about this.
Do you forgive me?
Yeah.
Oh,
I got to say yes.
No I'm not.
I'm posing,
posing strong arming them.
It's interesting to get some feed bumps.
Sure.
Sarah will give you some feedback on yeah,
it's subtle,
but it,
and I'm saying really the,
it's more prevalent,
I don't think have ever asked for a person's forgiveness.
I've said that.
I've said,
you know,
sorry and apologize for all kinds of stupid things that I've done,
but I don't think I've ever asked for forgiveness.
Maybe if this was something really big.
Yeah.
But even then,
man,
yeah,
that's a tough one.
I am sure she has a little great reason behind it.
We'll have to give further explanations.
Yeah,
I thought of that because I considered like saying that in some minor situation
whenever and then I'm like,
wait.
In minor situations it's too much.
Yeah.
Like you know,
a show to play,
man.
I'm sorry,
will you forgive me?
Like,
no,
this is a little too much.
It's like saying,
Hey,
I know I,
you know,
I know I made you bad,
or something like that.
I know I made you mad and I'm sorry.
You know,
whatever.
Are you still mad?
It's kind of like that because if you say,
yeah,
I'm still mad.
It's kind of like flight.
Hey,
I said my piece,
you chose not to be met or you chose to continue to be mad.
That's your problem kind of thing.
It's like,
do you please forgive me?
Please forgive me.
Like what kind of a Dick doesn't forgive someone?
You know?
It's kind of like that and they're bringing that so it's like a little strong.
I said,
we'll get feedback where it's,
it's an interesting,
we'll get feedback from Sara.
I'm sure.
It's interesting to think that there's people out there and you know,
they're out there that,
hey,
don't apologize.
It's a sign of weakness.
It's just being dumb.
Yeah.
Here's,
here's the advice for today.
Don't be dumb.
Yeah.
It kind of goes the,
the apologizing and taking extreme ownership.
I say nuts.
Similar.
I think there's a big overlap there.
Oh,
there's huge it.
I didn't say there were not similar.
Oh,
no,
no.
Not that.
Not the same thing.
Sorry.
Yeah,
they're not,
they're not the same thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
um,
well back to the thing when you were like,
Yo,
if you don't apologize,
that's weak or whatever.
That's kind of like the guy who says like,
Hey,
this is how I am.
Take it or leave it kind of thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
if they're a dick,
you know,
or something like that and they're like,
take it or leave it.
Some people love me,
some people hate me.
It's kind of thing.
And by that doesn't bother you that people hate you because of how you are,
you know,
kind of thing.
It's going to be gator.
Yeah.
You know,
so it's kind of weird.
I mean,
yeah,
I'd take it,
you know,
be you for sure.
But,
um,
I think that's something,
it's not nothing if people hate you.
Let's do one more question.
As person in a
leadership position,
what should I do if I consistently noticed one of my guys motivating the team
and leading them successfully during projects emissions better than I can,
the completion of the mission being the top priority,
would it be better for me to back down and let my counterpart lead,
which will benefit the company and its employees?
And how will I regain my status among them?
I think this one's actually pretty straightforward.
If you've got someone that's doing a better job leading,
then let him lead.
Let him lead.
Give him some room.
Learn from them,
support them the best you can.
And the best way you can most likely support them is by getting out of the way
and letting them do what they're doing and then get them the support that they
need.
And what this is going to give you the benefit of is now you can,
instead of looking down and in and managing your team,
you can look up and out and forward and see what is going on in the future and
prep the battlefield and in the future or prep the next market area or look for
recruiting.
You know,
you can move,
you can lead,
you can actually lead
and let that,
you know,
young buck,
handball,
the things that are going on tax free on the battlefield right now.
I used to say this to the,
to the see leadership.
I used to say,
Hey,
the enlisted seal leaders handle the problem that is in their face right now.
The tackle promise interface right now,
the officer should be looking at what we're going to do next.
That's kind of a really simple,
it's not always like that,
but that's a real good starting point,
and so in this position I'd be like,
oh,
I got a young buck that's coming up and leading.
Well,
cool.
That's going to allow me,
allow me to look up and out and be ready to move forward and plan the next move.
Now,
as far as regaining your status as a leader,
you won't really need to because if you do this properly,
you'll be seen as a leader who is confident enough to let a subordinate leaders
step up and lead while I go and move forward.
The w w you'd have to regain if you were there shutting this person down and
trying to micromanage and doing a worse job than everyone on the team knows that
that guy could do a good job,
let them do it.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's about confidence really.
It's about like,
do you have,
are you confident and are you secure in your leadership?
Oh yeah.
To step aside,
step aside that it's,
yes,
no problem.
We love it.
Hey,
you're,
you're really good at that school.
You,
you step in there and do it.
I don't have a problem with that.
Will you get the occasional person that's like,
Oh look,
Jack was jack was let that guy do it cause he doesn't know what he's doing
occasionally.
Yeah.
One out of 20 people will be that big,
Mr. Negative.
That's fine.
You know,
then,
then what's cool is when you're on the outside,
guess what you are,
when you're,
when you let someone else run the team,
guess what you have.
Guess what you have detached.
Yes.
Oh,
Echo Charles.
You have detachment.
And so now you're going to be able to see things that even that bleeder that's
better than you can't see.
And then when you come in,
you're gonna look like the tactical genius because you point something out.
But they didn't notice cause they were in the firefight.
Tactical genius.
The way it works,
things get,
yeah.
That's hard to do that man.
When someone's doing better than you,
you don't.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
that's right.
I mean the OIC at kw takes confidence as what you say.
This is such a good example of keeping your ego in check because what you just
said,
everyone feels that and when you feel that,
that's when you go,
oh cool,
my ego's getting out of control.
It's fine.
Just put it in check and let this person to lead and I'll move,
you know,
check out what we're going to do next.
I'll look ahead on the battlefield.
She don't want,
I'm trying to think like how you said there.
Occasionally there'll be a guy,
it would be like,
oh,
he doesn't know what he's doing.
So he's letting I,
I've been in that situation where my boss actually,
I've been the guy who,
my supervisor like said,
Oh yeah,
you like you to handle,
you take this,
you know you got this one kind of thing.
And I'm like,
yeah,
you're doing it because you don't know what you're doing kind of thing.
And everyone knew that.
And so I've been in that situation where I'm looking at them,
but now think about this,
think about if instead of him just saying,
Hey,
you go on and run the same thing.
If he would've said,
hey,
echo,
you're really good at this,
you're better than I am.
You step up,
run this.
I'm going to be over here looking at where we're going next.
What would you think then?
Yeah,
so he's actually said that before like a couple times and it every single time
it made me feel way better.
Like buddle um,
even the,
I mean,
of course the truth will set you free.
Yeah.
So I feel like if I was one of the only,
you know,
one of the top guys on the team's thinking that,
I think I wouldn't think that if,
yeah,
if he did that kind of stuff now Turriff or if as long as he didn't act like
counterintuitive,
you think that if you hide it,
it's better.
And the better thing to do is be like,
hey,
echo is really good at this.
He's better than I am and he's going to step up and run this thing and people
are like,
oh wow.
Jack was super confident as leadership.
They don't,
they don't verbalize in their head that,
right.
That's just the feeling,
the feeling that no Tacos,
Taco doesn't care who's running this thing.
He's just,
yeah,
we're good.
It's good,
man.
Yeah.
So watch out for that Gatorade member though.
Just keep your ego in check.
Yes,
sir.
At all times.
All right,
let's have a podcast that's less than 19 hours long.
So
how can you maybe give us a hand with helping be prepared and getting better in
our lives?
Chapo,
Charles,
go be happy to do.
No problem.
Okay,
so we're working out.
We're all working out.
Yes,
100% right every day.
Are we working on every day?
So you don't have to,
not necessarily half do,
but a lot will say we recommend it.
Yeah.
We're not working out and then cruising for month.
So we're all working out.
Look,
we're going to supplement our stuff.
Jocko does how supplements now,
that was kind of the plan the plan has come to fruition.
That's a word right?
Fruition.
So we used it correctly.
Yeah.
See.
All right,
there you go.
So krill oil,
right?
That's the main one for our joints.
Actually.
It's good for your eyes and brain too,
by the way.
So worry.
I'm not saying don't worry about your eyesight anymore after you take this.
I'm saying you can worry less to tell you that.
That's good.
So yeah,
Jocko supercrew is what it's called and joint warfare.
That one's obviously for the joint specifically,
but I'm sure there's all kinds of other benefits.
I've noticed my Ivan injured arm.
Sure.
It's healing up quickly by no,
like noticeably each day.
And I have to attribute,
cause I've had this similar injuries before.
Right.
It's an unlock.
And as bad as this one was little noises.
It is noticeably,
I'm attributing that to joint warfare.
Yeah.
And Dean told him the other day I,
Dean told me exactly like,
like his version of what happened.
And I know that,
I know that move that he shows even when he shows it on me,
deans one on these guys were,
I think sometimes he doesn't know his own style.
And what he's doing is super effective.
By the way.
It's like it's a Kimora.
That's what he's doing.
It's like the,
the,
what he did to me was I straight arm lock.
So that's what it ends up being.
Just so everyone knows,
I'll just make this real clear.
This was,
uh,
this was an accident.
Dean was actually showing a move.
He wasn't even,
we weren't rolling,
it wasn't live.
Q was showing a move and he's shown 10,000 moves with me as the dummy.
And I'm shown many,
many moves on Dean with Dina's,
the dummy.
And he got this position.
I had just arrived.
And I don't know if that makes it worse or not,
but I was definitely what's called,
you know,
so I was cold and no warm up and he was showing a moose.
So he's just highly,
I want to show this thing.
I think it was like you jock,
who's got a good defense here,
so you've gotta be ready if the guy does this.
And then he's like,
as you were saying that,
I think he thought I was going to attempt this movement and I didn't.
And he just,
he just,
he meet in the arm.
So is that pretty much how he debriefed it to you?
Yeah,
but the thing,
the reason I understood it,
because more is that be this guy,
you know,
he feels about it and then,
I mean,
it's a bummer.
Yeah.
This is not like,
I know,
I know for a fact he didn't mean to do it.
Whatever.
Yeah.
It's one of the,
it's basically how he explained it and he's done this move.
Like I said,
as me as the dummy,
and it hurts by the way.
You know what's funny?
He goes,
he goes,
I didn't realize you weren't that flexible.
I go,
Bro,
it's my elbow.
There's no flexibility in an elbow.
Well,
it must have been a miscommunication.
Just like I said,
because this is what it was.
It's like,
Eh,
okay.
When you go in for the Kimora from across site,
these are,
you want to get his arm behind his back,
bend his arm basically,
and behind his back.
That's what he said.
And that's a move he's had showed it to me before it and it's one of his things,
his tricks and he,
he said that like when he,
it
just like a miss community,
you know,
like if you,
and if you do it,
it's kind of like you're just,
it's just leverage to bend your arm behind your back.
But [inaudible] and it was,
it wasn't your shoulder them jam,
notice your right elbow.
And I'm thankful about that.
Shoulder injuries are worse than elbows.
Elbows is like the heel,
you know.
And even this one I can do like I'm,
I'm,
it'll be fine.
Yeah,
no factor.
Yeah.
You got the joint warfare.
Yup.
I attribute the quick healing to join warfare Krill oil,
which I always take joint warfare.
Yeah.
And that's,
and these are one of those ones that is kind of like,
man,
I wish I would've,
it would've saved me a lot of pain in the past.
Like if your joints are just holding up,
it's more of a big deal.
That's good.
And it's like I said,
I mean I had my shoulder where I couldn't do muscle ups for like six months and
then when we came out with their first like experimental,
no,
like the second experimental uh,
joint warfare and I was on,
I was like all of a sudden I was doing muscle ups again,
which is,
that's awesome.
Right.
That's awesome.
Well shoot,
doing muscle ups period is awesome cause I haven't Tang muscle ups,
I haven't done muscle.
Ups were decades really my whole life.
I don't think I've ever done a muscle up before in for decades.
I think I've tried to do a muscle up probably like three times a week.
As soon as we get done,
we're going to do some muscle ups.
Teach me the technique.
It's technique.
Well there's techniques,
there's a little bit of strength obviously,
but if you know the false grip,
which is this main,
the main technique that needs to be learned,
keep it in tight to your chest,
pull it to your sternum,
boom,
throw it,
throw your chest forward and you're there.
All right,
cool.
She's new skill,
a muscle up.
But yeah,
if you want this a joint warfare and Jocko Super Krill.
It is@originmain.com main like the state or didn't mean.com also at origin main
is where you can get your geese.
Oh,
but before the geese I,
this is new so I can't tell this new supplement called the discipline.
Pre mission,
pre workout,
pre life activity,
pre life supplement.
Um,
that's a good one.
Cognitive enhancements in there as well as physical pre mission.
You're going to need your brain and your body.
Boom for the mission.
Boom.
That's the one to take.
Yeah,
get down unknown's good.
By the way,
it tastes good too.
Surprisingly actually made it tastes good.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well because the big thing you got to watch out for is,
you know,
we don't want to spike our insulin level with sugar,
but we have monk fruit,
which is the sweetener and and monk fruit case.
Good delish and,
and it also has some positive impact on your physiology as well.
So double two w we say there we say two birds.
One stone industry ran on what those days?
Good.
Yeah,
it's good.
Lemon or lime flavor.
Yeah,
there you go.
Get down.
But yeah,
that one to origin main.com real good.
Also at origin main,
like I was going to say is gies for all the people who have been asking.
Dave Burke today called me today about geese.
Like what up with the gays,
I'm getting muggy and all this stuff you've been doing,
which was even questioning,
he was actually asking more.
Well,
yeah,
he did.
He was like,
what?
Gee should I get?
But then I was like,
well,
okay,
so you go hard Janie.
And he's like,
no,
I know that.
But
the traditional geese sizes just like a one,
a two,
three boom,
you get it.
But this one is kind of,
it's more suited for you.
So he had some questions.
Skinny.
I got a picture.
I got to post this picture.
I've got a picture of Dave Burke and me,
the commander.
I'm the commander of tea.
You bruiser.
He's the commander of lightening six.
His uh,
Anglico team and I've got a picture of us in Ramadi together on a rooftop and
were both asleep.
He must've been,
I don't even know what it was taken,
but it's pretty awesome.
And it shows you like,
like you know it's eyes,
you know,
it's awesome.
It's like we're both asleep.
We both have all of our gear on sitting on the side on a rooftop asleep.
So what is that like?
You just got to,
I've got to catch her sleep when you can.
Let me just keeps this quick.
Probably we,
my guess is we had moved into a position,
we'd stayed there,
we'd could,
a clearance was going on,
the clearance was done and now we were kind of,
you know,
stand by situation and we're just like,
now we get a chance to do,
because before we'd go in the field,
he'd be asleep.
You'd be awake for basically like 24 hours,
then you go in the field better of fact,
sometimes it's like when you go out in the field is when you got your first
sleep.
Like after you get the field and then you get your four hour of whatever,
three hours,
someone,
you know,
you get your head down and you get some sleep.
Finally there's me and Dave Burke racked out barely.
And it's not like you're like how you said three,
four hours.
I always,
especially after hearing you guys talk,
it's like man,
it's not like you're coming home from a hard day of work and you know,
now you're,
you've clocked out and now you have some time to settle down,
watch the news and go sleep for the night and not like down on,
you know,
going to catch some.
Yeah,
you're going to catch where you can.
So Dang,
that's crazy.
So it's not that you guys are just falling asleep on the job literally.
No,
no,
no.
Not at all.
Catch some,
some shuttle.
What that means is we are probably on the tail end of a operation that we had
conducted and we were now like in a stand down mode and maybe we are probably
getting ready to move to another,
you know,
another quadrant,
another sector and we're just catching some brack ops.
But it's an awesome,
it's an awesome picture cause it just tells you how like tired you,
you know,
we're both sitting in chairs,
all of our gear on holding our guns and we're asleep.
Both of us.
It's awesome.
And bed nonetheless.
Dave Burke.
Yeah he called me.
Nonetheless.
That story doesn't matter.
You want to get a g you still looking to get a gig.
You want to get another geek,
get it from origin may not come made in America.
Hundred percent made in made in America from the seeds of the cotton that said
it either the cotton all the way up to the g you wearing people like when you
say cotton sure.
And they like when you say important,
important
in mountain cause you got about mountain.
Yeah.
Breath cause you and I feel weird if I say mountain mountain or important,
it's like I'm not important for me that's just like,
yeah,
no I dig.
It doesn't sound weird when you do it.
It's,
it feels weird.
Let me do it.
Unless you or do you mean.com that's the goal there.
They have a lot of cool stuff and it's all made in America.
That's the good part.
It's all made in America also for workout stuff.
Kettlebells,
battle ropes,
maces you're switching up your work.
Are you doing creative stuff?
Boom.
On it.
On dotcom.
Slash.
Jocko that's where you go.
The kettle bells,
the artistic one,
primal bells,
demon bell's,
not demon build.
Zombie bells is what they're called and primal beltway prom.
Zombied legend.
Yeah,
plenty to pick from.
What was the cool ones?
I bought my daughter one a few months ago by the way.
She gets after.
Nonetheless.
That's where you get them.
A lot of cool stuff on there.
A lot of good info as well on it.com/jocko that's the one also,
when you're buying the books that we occasionally and occasionally meaning very
often review on this podcast.
Go to Jocko podcast.com the page little top menu there.
Click on books.
When podcasts click through this good way to support.
That's where you buy them.
We have more organized for you so you know you don't get lost or whatever listed
by episode.
Click through there and get on Amazon,
Amazon prime next day delivery.
Best Way to do it in my opinion.
Also subscribe to the podcast.
If you have not already on iTunes,
Google play,
stitcher,
Spotify.
Wait,
can you subscribe on spot?
I think he can.
I don't know.
I don't know either.
I'm not on Spotify,
but
if you are on Spotify and you can subscribe,
subscribe also on Youtube video version of this podcast.
Also excerpts from this podcast.
The benefits of excerpts I think are kind of self explanatory and I've explained
them plenty of times so I'm not going to do it this time.
Um,
but yeah,
you can take your little uh,
lessons individually so you have listen to the whole podcast nonetheless.
Subscribed.
Good way to support.
Also talk as a store.
It's called Jocko Jocko store.com.
This is where you can get the shirts.
Discipline equals freedom.
A shirt with Jacola's head on it with the word good.
Written backwards.
I'm not going to say why it's written backwards,
but it is written backwards on purpose because people have been emailing you.
And by the way,
if you see a shirt with the good written forward,
it's a fake shirt.
It's a knockoff.
It's what's called a counterfeit knockoff.
It's bad.
Actually somebody posted a picture of,
I forget what it's,
it's a Jocko Giacosa.
It's one of those,
you know those k there.
So there's like companies that they go,
you know,
they form stores on Amazon,
see little something that might be computer thing and they'll they print shirt.
They're like low quality one that said you wouldn't understand it.
It's junk junk thing.
That's the one I saw.
And they were like,
hey,
you know,
that could in being a cool hey man,
good meet some random dude out there.
And I,
to me the quote was I,
I would never put that coat on there.
I don't think you would.
Doesn't seem like something you would put,
you will understand,
you know,
kind of the,
the guy looked cool in it and then I dig it.
But I'm good.
Nothing intention,
good intention for sure.
100% and I'm signing on in that way.
But I think again,
it's a situation where these comfort,
I'm assuming it's a company,
I'm sure it's not just one dude,
but it's companies,
they get trendy stuff and they just offer them for print in on Amazon or
wherever and that's different.
That's what they called counterfeit knockoff John Lewis Store and then you're
definitely supporting the podcast.
Yeah,
junk store.com that's it.
And there's some origins of like a beck and origin may and they got the your
rash guard origins stuff,
hundred percent in the game podcast legit.
Other than that,
it's good.
It's going to be kind of hard to find,
well no the t Jocko white tea to supporting the podcast,
but anything else is going to be not costing,
you know,
kind of find that every once in a while.
So just be where if you care,
if you care a dig it because to me,
if,
if someone was wearing,
it's a jungle thing,
you wouldn't understand.
They were like,
hey,
good evening or something like that.
I'd be done.
That'd be my new friend.
To me.
So a day,
a hundred percent either way,
but I think that's more just info,
you know,
information.
Yes.
It's one of,
back to [inaudible] story.
There's this women's stuff on their discipline equals from tee shirts,
hoodies,
hats.
I don't think it beanies,
I didn't finish the beanies yet,
but a meeting on Monday,
you know that,
you know,
it's one of those things,
we're trying,
we're over here making sure you are aware of the seasons.
They're the same every year.
Maybe we'll do like a spring beanie,
uh,
some rash codes on there right now since it's negative 40 degrees in New England
in Minnesota and an Oklahoma freezing Chicago.
Michigan.
Yeah.
Sorry guys.
They're coming though.
It's all good.
Um,
also rash guards.
There's a new rash guard,
sodium one,
the essence of Jujitsu,
small action.
Big Reaction.
You know,
and that got pointed out to me after I started wearing it by the way.
Someone applied a layer.
A layer.
Yeah.
Black belt.
He was keeling Taylor who did it and he was like,
Oh,
what is your restaurant say?
Says it's a small action,
big reaction.
And it goes to the essence of Jujitsu is the whole leverage and efficiencies
being.
I was like,
Dang,
Bro,
you're,
you're speaking of judo queuing.
Judo.
Keeling.
Yeah.
He's black belts.
Do the original judo player.
Yeah.
Legit nonetheless.
New rash out.
Oh,
it's cool.
It's cool.
Uh,
the word you'd rash guards are out and in circulation in the wild pig time of
oil.
I haven't seen the person in the wild,
but I've seen them.
Yeah.
Truly.
Truly cyber cyber.
The cyber space.
Wild.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's cool.
When people do that and send you the pictures,
but nonetheless.
Yeah.
Jocko,
store.com.
That's a good one.
Also,
psychological warfare,
of course.
If you didn't know what that is,
I'm going to tell you it's an album with tracks,
chocolate track and this is what it's for.
If you didn't know,
I'm going to explain it.
This is what it's for on your path to,
I want to make it like concise.
Okay.
Here's a good way to say it.
On Your path to greatness.
It's a weapon against weakness.
It's kind of concise.
I'm still working on it.
I just made it up.
Just not concise yet.
Cheesy.
Somehow have to greatness.
So cheesy.
Don't say it again,
Bro.
Yeah.
Cc.
This is the,
what do you call it?
The creative process.
Yeah.
This is like,
oh,
that was just cheesy.
There wasn't no awesome live on the podcast.
Just the worst.
Worst deal.
All right,
well,
hey,
look on your path.
How about that?
On the path you're on the path on the path.
We're working out,
we're working out.
We're getting up early.
Some of us,
most of us,
some of us,
you know,
barely
sticking with the dietary guidelines that didn't keep us in the game.
Hopefully we better be nonetheless everyone.
Every once in a while you'll hit that little roadblock.
Little speed bumps,
speed bump,
not roadblock,
speed,
bump moment of weakness.
All It is a distraction.
Like can't.
When you get hungry,
you're on a fast or you're on,
you know,
like a really solid diet and maybe it's new or something
you're thinking long term.
Hopefully you're thinking longterm,
longterm.
When my dad,
it's going to bring me my workout.
My whole thing is going to bring me to this longterm goal.
Right.
You keep your eyes in that goal.
You're going to stay on the path.
You get distracted by the fact that you're hungry at one moment.
The fact that this thing right here,
donuts,
whatever tastes good,
you're distracted by that.
If you keep your eyes on the longterm goal,
you won't be distracted and then it doesn't mean anything.
Yeah.
No,
I'm hungry right now.
I supposed to be hungry at night to meet.
Yet of course donuts tastes good.
They always taste good.
It has nothing to
do with this pat.
That's why these are distractions.
This psychological warfare is,
it's like a little helper to keep you from being distracted and it's Jockos
telling us why we should not be distracted.
All right.
Thank you.
That was psychological warfare.
I do.
It is,
that's exactly what it is.
That's the best way to explain it.
And you just explained it thoroughly.
I feel like you don't,
you don't.
You know why you don't understand the value?
Because you don't listen to it.
No.
Yeah,
I do know.
Because you've never,
yeah,
like the like you having to use it I think is like the kind of,
oh you're just going to think it's Kinda,
it's just part of the game.
You know?
For us it's like have listened to it but I don't like to utilize it on the
regular tree.
Utilize something and get that little wind with it.
Your Brow,
you're going to be like,
okay,
this thing works.
This thing is legit.
Just like Jujitsu.
It's an album on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
that type of stuff.
That's where you can get it.
Speaking of Amazon,
also on Amazon you can get something called Jocko white tea,
which might sound like it's simple.
Drink.
Sure.
You put water,
you put some tea in the water.
What you don't know is that once you drink the tea,
you now have a guaranteed deadlift of 8,000 pounds.
So drink Jocko white tea and dead lift more.
We've got some books way the warrior Kid Jujitsu,
studying,
reading,
working out.
It's for kids,
but adults can get something out of it to,
somebody posted a straight up rocky training montage,
but it was like an eight year old kid getting after it and it was all,
he's like sitting intensely reading warrior kid and then he's hitting mitts and
he's intensely reading or your kid that he's doing pushups.
So yeah.
Uh,
you can get that book where the Warrior Kid,
the next warrior kid book is coming out April 28th I'll tell y'all when it comes
out and is available for preorder.
What's the name?
Can you tell us?
The name is,
the name is Wei.
The warrior kid.
Mark's mission.
Yeah.
Mark.
Mark learned some new lessons.
I'll read some excerpts from it on the podcast in the coming months.
Just,
you know,
some little tastes of Mark's mission.
Extreme ownership.
Of course.
That is the book that I wrote with my brother Leif Babin
combat leadership for business in life,
how to take ownership,
which I talked a little bit about today.
Discipline equals freedom.
The field manual,
how to get after it mentally,
physically get some if you want the audio version of that.
It is not on audible.
It is on MP3,
iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play and other MP3 platforms.
Ashkelon Front is our leadership consultant company.
I had a guy talking to a potential client company was like,
Hey,
can you help us establish a culture of leadership inside of our company and I'm
like,
that is as what we do,
so if you need help with leadership at your company,
reach out to us.
It's me.
It's Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
emails info@echelonfrontdotcomoryoucangotoourwebsiteechelonfromdocfront.com if
you want a keynote speech,
you don't need to go to a speaker's bureau.
You can just contact us on front.com that's the more efficient,
effective way to make it happen.
On top of that,
we have the muster.
David,
we talked about it a little bit today.
Sure.
The the muster is a leadership symposium where we talk about leadership.
We train leadership pragmatically tools.
You will be,
you will.
This is pretty cool.
You will be a better leader when you come out of the monster,
you will be 100% I don't know if you'll be 100% better of a leader,
you will have a hundred percent chance or 100% chance of becoming a battle
better leader.
How much?
I'm not 100% sure on that figure,
but you will definitely be a better leader.
And when we got done,
I think I've talked about this before,
but when we got done in Austin and we are at Jujitsu and we were teaching Jiu
Jitsu and I was like this is such a good deal yeah.
To to get the information that comes at the muster,
to have that opportunity to learn these lessons from the battlefield that you
can then take and apply to your business and your life.
And on top of that,
like the icing on the cake is,
is going to Jujitsu and getting it in an introduction to that.
So the roster,
it's been awesome.
It's been awesome to see how it's affected people afterwards that have changed
their lives from coming to the monster.
So it's awesome.
Come and get some at the monster.
It is.
This year we're only doing two.
One is going to be in Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th then there's going to be San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th we have had four of these events up until now.
They all sold out.
Visa will sell out.
So if you want to go,
a lot of times when people,
when companies,
companies have bureaucracies inside of them and so they're trying to get the
approval for the,
you know,
hey we,
we need eight tickets and they're trying to run that through the chain of
command and get the funding for the eight tickets and blah,
blah,
blah.
And we've had companies that have started that process too late.
And then we sell out and we're sitting here saying,
hey,
sorry,
the next muster's in six months you can come then.
You know what I mean?
So get busy now takes while to get through your Burger cratic system at your
company to get your team sent to the muster.
We'll see you there.
Extreme ownership.com is how you can register.
And if you want to contact maybe me,
maybe echo,
if you want to share something with us,
you have some kind of question,
you have some kind of an answer,
you have some kind of a comment and you want to make,
we're actually available on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on that other one it's called the face up.
Keep ball hot echo is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and a fine
leave.
Thank you for listening to the show.
Thank you for supporting the show.
Thank you for spreading the word.
And for those of you that serve,
thanks for your service.
Those of you that protect thanks for your protection and for those that have
fallen,
okay,
those that we never got to say goodbye to
those that we never got to thank
to all of you.
Okay,
thank you.
And Goodbye.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.